c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bien mis sur france 24 à la
une ce soir l'ultime avertissement de
l'onu sur la situation en somalie le
pays est au bord de la famine une
famille nantie les fonds n'arrivent pas
immédiatement nous ferons le point avec
notre correspondant dans la région il
s'est rendu dans le nord du pays il ya
quelques semaines son témoignage dans un
enfant cette nouvelle attaque au burkina
faso l'explosion d'une bombe artisanale
dans le nord du pays a fait au moins 35
morts dont des enfants la situation
sécuritaire est très instable nous
aborderons entre autres cette question
avec abdoulaye sall ministre du
développement industriel et du commerce
il est notre invité ce soir et à la fin
de ce journal je vous emmène explorer
les fonds sous-marins au sénégal des
écologistes dakarois ans l'idée de créer
des musées d'oeuvres d'art sous longue
pour protéger l'environnement les
détails à la fin de cette édition
la faim et la soif ont jeté un million
de personnes sur les routes de somalie
depuis 2000 21 aujourd'hui la situation
est désastreuse la crise humanitaire
menace le pays en raison d'une
sécheresse sans précédent
martinez griffiths le chef du bureau de
la coordination des affaires
humanitaires de l'onu s'est dit
profondément choqué par la situation
laurent bercé cher
consternée et choquée par sa visite du
centre de la somalie le chef de l'agencé
humanitaire des nations unies est formel
le pays est actuellement au bord de la
famine et le pire reste encore à venir
preuve une chose
j'ai été profondément choqué par la
douleur et la souffrance auquel tant de
somaliens sur son rnb
la femme il est à la porte et nous
recevons aujourd'hui
après quatre saisons de pluies
insuffisantes consécutive la somalie vit
aujourd'hui une sécheresse historique
elle subit également les répercussions
de la guerre entre l'ukraine et la
russie selon l'onu près de 8 millions de
somaliens sont affectés par la
sécheresse dont plus de 200 mille
personnes directement menacées par la
famine
face à l'urgence les nations unies
appellent à une mobilisation rapide des
acteurs humanitaires
la seule chose qui peut empêcher la
famine dans ces régions de somalie on
serait une réponse humanitaire d'ampleur
sans effort significatif de notre part
de nombreuses vies seront perdues
en 2011 la somalie avait été frappé par
une famine dévastatrice qui avait fait
plus de 250 mille morts les experts
craignent aujourd'hui un bilan encore
plus lourd alors qu'une cinquième saison
de pluie défaillante est attendu à
l'automne
pour en parler on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondant dans la région à
bastien renouil bastia vous étiez il y a
quelques semaines en immersion dans le
nord de la somalie avec la fao
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture
à quelles sont les conditions de vie et
le quotidien des populations sur place
bonsoir meriem est d'aller les
conditions de vie sont absolument
désastreuse pour vous les raconter je
vous parlais de deux endroits différents
que j'ai pu visiter avec la f1 ou alors
que nous circulions en voiture dans
toute la région du puntland
tout d'abord il ya le village de bender
salamin vie âge qui est situé à
proximité de la frontière avec
l'ethiopie jusqu'au mois de mars la fao
pouvait distribuer un petit peu d'argent
chaque mois aux villageois de manière à
leur permettre de continuer à vivre sur
place pour pouvoir acheter les denrées
nécessaires à leur survie et puis la fao
bien n'a plus d'argent et a dû stopper
ces versements depuis une très grande
majorité du village a dû fuir 80 % de
ses habitants ont quitté la région pour
se réfugier dans des grandes villes ou
alors on it shopi où il ya un petit peu
plus de pluie dans ce village tous les
réservoirs sont à sec puisque cela fait
quatre saisons des pluies qu'il ne pleut
pas en réalité notamment dans la région
du puntland la majorité des animaux sont
morts les arbres meurent aussi la
végétation si il n'y a plus rien sur
place la vie est devenu tout à fait
insupportable puis je vous le disais
nous circulions dans tout ça a dit
région du puntland et plus au nord dans
un endroit qui est fortement atteint par
les tempêtes de sable les rafales
atteignaient les 100 km/heure et bien
des centaines de familles de déplacés
avaient décidé de s'installer là elle
avait fui la côte du puntland qui est
une région extrêmement aride où les
vents sont très forts il n'y avait plus
rien sur place ils ont décidé de
s'installer dans cet endroit qui est
situé au milieu de nulle part si je peux
le dire il n'y a rien sur place à part
un peu d'eau de l'eau salée mais de
l'eau quand même ils n'en avaient pas là
où il vivait avant ils ont décidé de
s'installer là et attendait depuis 40
jours que de l'aide humanitaire arrive
et c'est dead n'arrivait pas le
gouvernement somalien est au courant
qu'ils sont sur place mais la somalie
est un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde et le gouvernement n'avait pas les
moyens de les aider alors bastien
quelles sont les difficultés que
rencontrent les organismes
internationaux pour aider les
populations
eh bien il ya deux principales
difficultés tout d'abord la menace du
groupe terroriste islamiste al chabaab
qui contrôlent encore une très grande
partie du pays notamment au sud de la
somalie et qui empêche toute
organisation humanitaire toute
organisation onusienne de pouvoir
accéder à ces zones et dans le reste du
pays bien la logistique est extrêmement
compliqué il faut se déplacer en
véhicule est blanc d difficile de rester
à l'extérieur des bases de l'onu trop
longtemps sans risquer de menaces du
groupe terroriste mais ce n'est pas le
problème le plus important pour l'onu et
pour les ong le plus important c'est le
manque de financement pour vous donner
l'exemple de la haye fao avec qui
j'étais en immersion durant une semaine
eh bien ils ont besoin de 130 millions
d'euros pour pouvoir répondre à l'aide
d'urgence humanitaire et sur 730
millions d'euros bien seuls 46 % de
cette somme ont été financés par les
bailleurs internationaux les pays et les
organisations internationales
ils ont besoin de plus pour pouvoir
venir en aide à la population et c'est
la même chose pour le programme
alimentaire mondial pour l'unicef et
pour de très nombreuses ong sans argent
ils ne peuvent rien faire ça fait très
longtemps que la crise dure en somalie
parfois près de 30 ans dans certaines
régions et certains bailleurs et bien se
lassent donne beaucoup moins il ya
d'autres urgences humanitaires ailleurs
notamment en ukraine par exemple et donc
il vient les fonds tarde d'arriver
pourtant ces fonds sont nécessaires
alors que la situation ne fait
qu'empirer vous le disiez il ya de
fortis qu'il n'y ait pas de saison des
pluies au point d'octobre ce serait la
cinquième d'affilée qui n'aurait pas
lieu cela serait catastrophique si
c'était le cas bien la situation ne
pourrait qu empirer en somalie où la
famine menace s'est fortement merci
beaucoup bastien vous allez nous livrer
un long reportage que vous avez tourné
lors de ce déplacement qui sera diffusée
prochainement sur nos antennes
selon bilan au burkina faso l'explosion
d'une bombe artisanale au passage d'un
convoi de ravitaillement entre djibo et
bourzanga dans le nord du pays a fait 35
morts et 37 blessés civils dans
plusieurs enfants la vieille de l'attak
dimanche soir le lieutenant-colonel
damiba avait dans un discours à la
nation salué une relative accalmie mais
les attaques restent nombreuses dans le
pays et on va en parler de la situation
sécuritaire au burkina faso avec
abdoulaye tall ministre du développement
industriel du commerce de l'artisanat et
des petites et moyennes entreprises il
est notre invité ce soir bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et d'être venu
sur notre plateau alors tout d'abord
votre réaction à cette attaque alors
merci pour l'invitation c'est d'abord
tristesse désolation mais compassion
malheureusement notre pays touché depuis
des années maintenant par ce genre
d'attaqués qui visent des populations
civiles mais cela montre aussi à quel
point nous devons nous unir pour faire
face au danger qui menace notre nation
c'est la seule solution c'est vrai que
nous avons l'appui des partenaires mais
la responsabilité de défendre le pays de
le mettre dans un état meilleur pour
tout le monde nous revient en tant que
boucle avec et c'est ce que nous devrons
faire un organe à la main cette attaque
prouve que le danger est permanent et
qu'il faut continuer à se battre à
s'ébattre à s'unir alors vous êtes venu
nous parler ce soir aussi du salon
international de l'artisanat de
ouagadougou le thème cette année et
artisanat africain et levier du
développement est facteur de résilience
des populations
pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème alors
comme vous le savez notre pays subit des
attaques ce qui engendre de déplacés
nous avions environ 2,2 millions de
déplacés internes et l'artisanat c'est
la première source d'emploi de se
déplacer c'est la première source de
réinsertion de se déplacer et donc c'est
un facteur de résilience et aussi les
xiao c'est c'est un salon biennal qui
qui n'a pu se tenir en 2020 à courre du
coup vide et donc ça fait quatre ans que
cet événement n'a pu se tenir il est
extrêmement important pour nos artisans
et les artisans africains en général
parce que c'est l'un des salons les plus
dynamiques de notre continent alors
c'est vrai que il y à des défis
sécuritaires qui bloquent l'accès à
certaines zones comme dit beau mais qui
menace aussi des zones de production
comme
la boucle du mouhoun notamment la zone
de solenzo mais il ya aussi une
organisation interne pour pouvoir y
répondre
c'est vrai aussi que certaines zones des
zones de production et il faut pouvoir
convoyer cette production vers les
centres de consommation qui sont des
centres urbains et cela a perturbé un
peu d'approvisionnement ce qui a
contribué aussi à créer un peu
l'inflation que vous avez dû constater à
travers les rapports mais dans
l'ensemble l'économie burkinabè se porte
bien elle est résiliente il y a des cas
de succès importants de l'industrie de
la banque et de la transformation et
c'est ce qu'il faut montre ici merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre d'être
venu sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes ministre du commerce de
l'industrie mais aussi de l'artisanat
des petites et moyennes entreprises je
rappelle aussi que le salon
international de l'artisanat de
ouagadougou se tiendra le 28 octobre
prochain merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
notre plateau
avant de se quitter je vous propose une
plongée sous-marine à dakar au sénégal
des écologistes dakarois ont décidé de
construire un musée sous l'eau en
plaçant des oeuvres d'art devenu des
refuges pour les espèces marines les
algues et les plantes aquatiques
une initiative qui devrait aider les
poissons à se reproduire et sensibiliser
contre la surpêche et la pollution
nos correspondants et l'hymne ndao et
samra dppi sont enfiler la combinaison
de plongée pour vous livrer ces belles
images reportage
oubli a hâte de découvrir le premier
musée soumaré d'afrique
après le briefing des instructeurs et
l'un fils son équipement direction la
mer pour ce qui sera sa toute première
plongée
je suis tout excité et j'ai un peu peur
mais j'ai hâte je suis né et j'ai grandi
les premiers habitants à dakar
waze lutte oeuvres d'art en béton ont
été installés à 4 mètres de profondeur
elles forment récifs artificiels sur
lequel des plantes aquatiques et des
algues ont poussé les sculptures sont
devenus des refuges et des lieux de
reproduction pour les poissons
cérébrale qui a trait et ce musée cet
écologiste sénégalais se bat depuis
plusieurs années pour protéger le
littoral dakarois
moi petit j'ai vu des gros poissons moi
petit j'ai péché du barracuda on
veut redonner la vie à la baie de la
canche en recréant la vie avec des
récifs artificiels
mais il faut de gros recife
donc c'est un début ça vient de démarrer
redouane se fixe comme objectif
d'atteindre 5 le mètre carré récifs
artificiels pour cela il compte sur la
contribution des artistes sculpteurs du
sénégal
c'est la fin de journal de l'afrique
l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]